hello uh this is fran diamond
i work at the center for forensic
science research and education
and uh what we're going to talk about
today is a very
interesting new product from waters
called the radium
radiant asap it is
could be described as a rapid drug
detection system
so we had a collaboration with waters to
test out their system and so
although this is still preliminary in
nature
uh i did want to share some of the
results that we had
uh with you
this is the outline kind of the the flow
of this uh
talk uh you know we're going to talk
about forensic chemistry because this
instrument this is a very exciting
instrument that
may build a role in forensic chemistry
testing
so we're going to talk about uh how that
would fill
that role when we talk about the
instrument we're just going to talk a
little bit about just the theory of
operation
you know what what is going on inside
the instrument
the mode of operation how does someone
sit in front of it and run this
uh we're going to generate some data so
we're going to look at
you know what does that data look like
and the utility of the data you know how
is this going to be data that
uh is of value in the forensic chemistry
community
um and then so then after that we're
going to talk about our specific project
with the collaboration with waters
and we actually involved nms labs
to provide us with some authentic
samples
from some seized from some drug seizures
that
we got in casework so these are
discarded
uh auto sampler vials but uh and so
we'll just talk about
uh the findings uh we'll discuss some of
the advantages
and some of the disadvantages of or the
radiant asap
system and then talk about future
considerations
and just kind of wrap that up with a
conclusion
so you know as i said the you know
our assessment was really to determine
how well this is going to work with
seized drug analysis
when it sees drug analysis uh you know
is
basically can be as easy as you have a
white powder that could be cocaine
you could have a brown mixture that
could be
any number of different compounds you
never know what you're going to get in
forensic chemistry so what we wanted to
do
is just determine is this would this be
applicable
to do some of that preliminary testing
that drug testing laboratories do a
traditional test
include some rudimentary color tests
some people might run a quick ftir
scan to get a feel for you know what
could the compound be
at the end of the day we want to have
two pieces of information
that are independent of each other that
kind of confirm
uh of what we're looking for so what we
wanted to do is to see if this radian
could fill that role uh of of just
providing
upfront data that is going to direct a
forensic chemistry
on what might be you know the next line
of testing
so in order to fill that role you know
it has to be easy so we're going our
evaluation was
including ease of use how easy is it for
a forensic chemist to
just uh sit in front
[Music]
of an instrument and generate this data
and then secondly the quality of the
data has to be
uh stand up to the scrutiny
of court okay and it also has to be
explainable by a forensic chemist
so um so the radiant system itself is
actually
a direct probe mass spectrometer okay so
we have the ability to
apply our sample to a glass capillary
and put that directly into the mass
spectrometer for
to generate data in seconds instead of
minutes okay there's no chromatography
it's really just inserting ionizing
and then reading our data and i'll
explain what the data look like
so swegdrug indian for us in the united
states
uh you know defines the quality
of various testing schemes category a
being the highest and so mass
spectrometry
is down here as a category a there are
other
category a's here too category b
includes techniques non-mass spectral
techniques like gas chromatography
liquid chromatography tlc uviz
and then their color c so these are kind
of the
least discriminatory tests that are done
and this includes color tests
um so these are the tests that are
[Music]
the category c may be the upfront tests
that are done to determine what the
material
is but category a really
provides much more detailed information
uh so as far as identification criteria
swig drug recommends that we
you know have at least one category a
technique and then we can follow that up
with some other techniques and that's
why
color tests are you know
[Music]
are performed so that we can get that
non-category a
test and then confirm that by something
like
typically gcms is is pretty much the
workhorse of
forensic chemistry laboratories
so i'm not going to explain each one of
these color tests but
you know over the years there have been
and a
large number of different color tests
that you know some very smart chemists
have come up with to
run to kind of determine up front
you know what kind of drug do we have
cobalt thiocyanate is probably one of
the most popular
it turns blue when you have a positive
cocaine
now that said that doesn't mean it's
absolutely cocaine there are other
things that are going to give a blue
color
and that that holds true for all of
these different color tests
but uh you know i just wanted to the
display
uh over the years people have used these
color tests
as a means of doing this upfront
confirmation now that takes time
that takes experience it takes a certain
amount of money preparing these reagents
so color tests while
not using expensive instrumentation
uh it does take time
and resources to run
so um i'm sorry
this is the radian asap system
all right so it's a very small
uh you know piece of equipment here
uh very small footprint doesn't take up
much
space on the lab bench doesn't require
high voltage what it does require is
nitrogen to come in and there's
very little waste that is generated
because
we don't have a effluent from an lc
coming in here so there's very little
waste that that is generated so as a
you can see it's a very uh compact unit
um ready to you know go i just
open the door this is where i'm sorry
so it's suitable for a wide range of
samples and basically because
we don't have to worry about a a dirty
injection
port or fouling a column we can
basically
put our samples directly into
the mass spectrometer okay so the
workflow is simple
dissolve your seized drug in a suitable
solvent it could be
in in water it could be in
methanol and you're just going to dry
off a capillary
and insert it directly into the mass
spectrometer
and you're going to start acquiring data
right away
and you're going to get a mass spec data
in less than a minute okay and
uh you know the quality of the mass spec
data
is really determined by processing by
the live id
software
okay so just to show you here the system
you have a glass capillary
you clean that you can apply your sample
to that capillary and then insert that
directly
into the mass spectrometer and hit start
live id is going to analyze that
data as it comes off in somewhat of a
unique fashion so i'm going to
show that in the upcoming slides so what
happens when we insert this directly
into the source okay so you can you can
see the capillary directly
in there we have a source of hot
nitrogen gas coming off
and we have a corona discharge
pin in there so this is very similar to
apci
in terms of ionization and
the nitrogen
serves to create this
corona discharge that is actually going
to end up ionizing our sample
so people that are familiar with lcms
know that
in apci under the right conditions
ionization is performed but we don't get
much fragmentation
and that's what we're going to
utilize here so initially we get
protonation
of or of our control substance and then
we can control what kind of
fragmentation happens next
and here is where we have that
fragmentation if we
look on the right hand side starting
from the bottom to the top
cv being cone voltage right so the
current voltage
actually promotes
additional fragmentation in the ion
source
by accelerating our charged particles
and causing additional
collisions and breakdowns so at a very
low
tone voltage we tend to get very little
fragmentation
and as we move that up to a cone voltage
of 25
and 35 and 50 you can see we get
subsequently
more and more fragmentation and that's
what
uh that's what we're doing in the system
when we do this
acquisition as soon as we hit start it's
going to run
through acquiring at these four
different cone voltages and what we can
do is basically we get
four different mass spectra or uh
everything that is added onto the column
i'm sorry there is no column um
okay so in the end here's what we get
uh live id will examine those four
traces and compare that to a database
where
the same process has been uh performed
on analytical standards and you get a
match factor a quality fit number in
this case we have codeine at 98
we also have a hip for hydrocodone and
those of you who are familiar with this
you know that these
two compounds are isomers of each other
they have very similar
mass spectra so it showed the
hydrocodone
probably as just a secondary hit
unless there's a trace of hydrocodone in
the sample
the one thing you're not going to get
with this system is you're not going to
get chromatographic separation
right so this is how our our data looks
don't be fooled we're not looking
at a peak this is just showing how
ions are uh formed inside the
source and this is just a trace of
everything that's positive
so this is actually an example of street
heroine
okay so this and as you can see
on the right hand side we have compound
and match score
we have fentanyl a very high probability
of fentanyl in here
we have diamorphine this is actually
probably
uh heroin or heroin breakdown
and then six monoacetyl morphine
so this is typical of what we see in
street heroin so this is a good
application
in that you can see it identified three
different forms
without chromatography and that's what
live id
does it pulls out data from those four
different voltages
and the algorithm in there searches each
one of them to determine if there's one
or multiple components in your sample
so here's an example where we get
a tablet submitted for testing
looks like alprazolam or xanax
okay so when we run live id
we find out actually it's flu outbreaks
of land
okay so this is this is one of these
counterfeit
uh compounds uh counterfeit formulation
containing one of these new uh we call
them novel psychoactive substances
um so this is
just an example of how live id and
rating system is going to help identify
something up front
again what we have here is we have the
four
different cone voltages of our sample
on top and the library entry on the
bottom
and what live id does is looks at those
four traces
to determine what is present you can see
here
we have a very good match actually at
the four different voltages
so basically the mode of operation is we
took some extracted samples from nms
labs
and these were random samples we just
said you know give us
you know uh 100 or 200 samples and you
know we'll start to work with them so we
just took them
we have evaporated the extracts that
they supplied
we took them down to dryness and we
reconstituted them in
50 microliters of acetonitrile we rinse
off the glass rod with methanol
we allow that methanol to dry
which is almost instantaneous and then
we're just going to submerge
the tip of the glass capillary into that
sample solution
we pull it out let it air dry again that
happens quite rapidly
and we load the glass rod into
a small little canister it just clips
right in
and when we insert it in the instrument
we can either choose to start the
acquisition
or we can start an acquisition of for
multiple samples
and uh you know we can discuss that
briefly
so before we start of course we want to
clean that glass rod
before and after we want to
demonstrate that we have a clean
background anyone
who's familiar with forensic chemistry
knows that a good lawyer can ask for
is it contamination from a previous
sample
so you know the glass rod you know we
want to run that as a blank injection
just to show that there are no drugs
and we may want to do this before and
after each sample
just to ensure that we don't have this
carryover
if we do have carryover we may have to
run
a blank acquisition uh you know numerous
times
as it turns out waters has developed a
fake out uh program that is actually
designed to clean out that chamber
between each uh acquisition
so uh you know that in our case we
were running multiple blanks between
samples with the big gap that may not be
necessary
so what we did is just to make sure that
we understood
how the system worked we ran just neat
standards we had
0.1 milligram per ml solutions and
we applied them onto the capillary put
them in
and we just searched it out to see if
our neet standards were identified
and if it was in the database they were
identified
we also have a standard test mix where
we have eight compounds
and we introduce that into the system
and
the radian asap system found six out of
the eight
compounds in the test mix and two
of those compounds methamphetamine and
centromere
isomers so we wouldn't expect
that both of them would have been
identified as individual components
and then when we as we ran
our samples the asap system was able to
detect
common controlled substances and in
addition to that some of the adulterants
again as long as they're in the library
it's going to find them
and so here's just an outline of the
comparison with testing with nms
labs uh and again these were random
exhibits that were set up for testing
and you can see
uh for samples of interest found by gcms
we have found fentanyl on these
and 39 out of 40 of them we
also found it on the radiant system
thc a little bit more problematic thc
is we're not quite sure what all the
issues
are with thc uh so uh
you know we spent a little bit of time
on this but we're
again we haven't completely resolved
this yet as far as methamphetamine
22 were found by gcms 19 on the radian
buprenorphine eight out of eight cocaine
uh seven out of eight now for a number
of these
exhibits uh the secondary
hits like thc were present
at much lower levels okay so the one
thing that you don't get
on the radiant system is the relative
concentration of these
of various compounds
so we also had numerous negatives and we
had to verify
that the asap system
also determined that these were negative
we didn't know what graphic to put up
here for negative samples so
we just put a statement up that 59
samples were
negative on both systems
so what are the challenges of sample
analysis
um mixtures mixtures are are going to be
you know problematic because we don't
know what the relative amounts of
different components are in these
mixtures what we have found that
is that the primary component seems to
be
the one that is identified faithfully
with the asap system
um we are working with waters on
problems with some
multi-component mixtures we did some
testing on the system
uh and i know that waters is
is working on improving this aspect
trace analysis so if you get a sample in
and you run it and you get a negative
does that mean it's negative or do does
it mean you have to concentrate your
sample
and that's really comes down to a
laboratory protocol
so you may or may not have to
concentrate your samples
another thing that because this is
positive ion
mode we're not going to see acidic
compounds
so the compounds of course you know they
don't ionize in positive
ion mode so uh compounds uh classes like
barbiturates
um nsaids they're not going to show
up
a problem that we saw is
signal saturation again
you're inserting a certain amount of
material directly into a mass
spectrometer
very sensitive mass spectrometer and
your
signal at times can get very high
for those of you who can read the
left-hand
margin for the y-axis where were in the
tens if not
hundreds of millions of counts here
and we do get a indication that we have
signal saturation
so the system determined that some of
the signal was saturated
and that's good and so it reports that
back to us
just to let us know hey your your top uh
your most prominent components here are
a little bit saturated you may want to
run
less to get a better quality match
so the advantages of this system
first of all i'm going to tell you on
day one
we just looked at each other the the two
of us working on this and said
this is awesome because you do
you literally you get a result
within one minute of high specificity
because it's mass spectrometry and
it has select ionization at these four
discrete ionizations so
we have the ability to identify drugs in
mixtures
without prior chromatographic separation
now the mixtures
is you know going to be problematic
because
all the different mixtures especially if
something's
present at trace concentrations are
going to challenge the system
but there's little to no sample
preparation
literally puts a couple milligrams in
uh a milliliter of of solvent
and you put the capillary into that and
introduce that into the mass
spectrometer so
sample preparation is very similar to
color tests
none it's really just aliquot in small
amounts
so what does this do it reduces user
intervention
okay that's that's a good thing okay
so you don't have to be a professional
at mass spectrometry to
generate data and that's not to say that
we're looking to put dummies in front of
it but we want to be able to
have a system that is a walk-up system
where you can readily generate data in a
short period of time
and because of the the nature of the
data
you can reduce some of the subjectivity
and decisions and bias that come
from running color tests
so it this is a faster screening method
when you compare to color test
and then layer there's you're not
waiting
for anything you're not putting a
sequence
on you're not uh you know doing all of
those things that
by their nature take time and this
variable cone voltage
is you know very good in terms of
it's a much added benefit to be able to
see
specific fragmentation at these
different
code voltages it's easy
minimal training is required so i'm
involved in teaching
an instrumental course for forensic
scientists
we had the system in-house so part of
our mass spec
lesson is i had them
the students run their unknowns they
were given unknowns and they ran it
on the system so they had minimal
training
we just told them here's what you can do
here's what you can't do
and they ran their samples and they got
their results
so because your data acquisition is mass
links
you can actually go back into the data
and do
more interactive analyses we did this
because we were wondering why
we weren't able to find traces of
compound a when compound b was present
and we went into mass lines and we could
see okay well it's there but
uh you know its intensity is much
smaller than
the major component so if you're
comfortable with mass links
you do have the capability of going
further than live id
[Music]
okay so some of the disadvantages are
going to be if you're used to
chromatography if you like that
separation you're not going to get it
with
a system like this so as such
uh because we can't separate compounds
out
um we're not going to be able to
identify
all the components in the single sample
because we don't always know what's in a
sample
sometimes we get carry over so the lab
is going to have to develop carryover
strategies when we were first learning
like i said thc caffeine these tended to
generate the most
carryover and as a result of what
the art art strategy was just to run
blanks over and over again
waters has this bake out procedure for
proceeding with this we did have some
trouble
with heroin matching to live id
we did actually work with waters on this
and they have
made progress on
being able to do uh identify heroin in
mixtures
this is could be seen as a disadvantage
is that we have limited user
intervention
the analysts can't change any parameter
except cone voltage
well you may want that because for
established methods in a forensic
chemistry laboratory
we we don't want to uh customize
everything that takes time it takes
uh folks having the know how to do that
so
the idea is that you walk up to the
instrument and generate data
you know that could be a disadvantage or
an advantage
see sequencing you know can be
problematic here because
you don't know what the carryover is
going to be
so the way we ran the system is we sat
in front of it
made acquisitions reviewed the data
and made a decision whether to go next
so in the sequencing uh
doesn't work in the traditional sense
where someone sits down in front of an
instrument types in 30 samples and walks
[Music]
away
so some of the future considerations
after working with waters
more library editions is going to help
us
for those samples that contained
components that were in the library they
were identified
but we need to add a number of
compounds to this database um at some
point i think it would be good to have
more interaction with the live id
software uh it's
it works great we don't understand the
algorithm but the
results are very good and then you know
we want to
try to test more challenging samples
just to see
can the system handle this
and you know can we process more complex
mixtures and
these are just strategies future
considerations that we have for the
system
so in conclusion the radian is very
robust
it is again you sit down
you insert the capillary and hit start
and you are able live id generates the
data
automatically the sample preparation
very simple because you're just diluting
results very rapid in a minute
okay so it's very amenable to labs
lacking advanced mass spectrometry
knowledge and skills
okay we don't we don't have that in
every laboratory
forensic chemistry laboratories they're
very good at gcms
but you know may not understand uh you
know
you know the complex nature of this
testing
so it's very amenable to labs that do
this
this uh type of work so
um with that um i'm finished my
presentation and
i will be willing to take some questions